[MUSIC PLAYING]
PRASHANTH VENKATARAM: By about
high school, I knew that I
wanted to do something
in physics.
I knew that MIT would be
a great place for that.
And I had heard about how
undergrads could do research.
ALEJANDRO RODRIGUEZ: Prashanth
is extremely
smart, extremely motivated.
One of the key things
undergraduates bring to the
table is a fresh perspective,
a willingness to essentially
try things that sometimes, a
sort of a seasoned researcher,
you sort of overlook.
You think you know what the
answer's going to be.
You let hubris essentially
take over.
And you don't explore things
that sometimes
undergraduates do.
And sometimes, they
hit the jackpot.
So what is this?
What are we looking at?
PRASHANTH VENKATARAM: These are
the plots of the average
flux with respect
to frequency.
And just for your convenience,
I've shown--
What I've been doing is to model
one particular type of a
new class of structures called
photonic crystals.
ALEJANDRO RODRIGUEZ: What
is a photonic crystal?
Well, it's a periodic structure,
with features where
the periodicity of the
structure is on the
wavelength of light.
PRASHANTH VENKATARAM: I'm
studying what frequencies and
wavelengths of light are emitted
the most when parts of
the crystal are excited.
Here, there are two very
distinct peaks where the
energy emitted is much higher
for those ranges of frequency.
ALEJANDRO RODRIGUEZ: The
importance of that work is
that a lot of these fluorescent
molecules are
being used to do spectroscopy
or to monitor cells or
microscopic and nanoscopic
objects.
Yeah, this is essentially
your unit cell
size, you know, lambda.
So for example, one might
think of essentially
piggybacking one of these
molecules in a tumor cell and
imaging, essentially, the
behavior of the tumor cell as
a function of time or as
a function of space.
PRASHANTH VENKATARAM: I mean,
if it's Lawrencian, it seems
fairly straightforward, right?
ALEJANDRO RODRIGUEZ:
Yeah, yeah.
PRASHANTH VENKATARAM: Research
is not limited to postdocs and
grad students.
Undergrads can do it, too.
And often, they contribute a
very vital role in some of the
research that goes on.
ALEJANDRO RODRIGUEZ: And this
is basically tangentially--
I was an undergraduate here.
One of the reasons I came to
MIT was actually because of
the UROP program.
Once you find what you're really
interested in or what
you want to do, you can
continue doing that.
And that can eventually
develop into
your graduate program.
I wouldn't be where I am today,
actually, if it weren't
for the UROP program.
[MUSIC PLAYING]